تغطتنا المباشره متواصله مشاهدينا لاثار
الزلزال العنيف والمدمر الذي ضرب تركيا
وشمال سوريا اعداد القتلى لا زالت في
ارتفاع مستمر فيما تتواصلوا عمليات
الانقاذ كما نشاهد الان واياكم على شاشه
العربيه بحثا عن ناجين الزلزال بلغت قوته
7.8 درجات على مقياس رختر السلطات التركيه
نائب الرئيس التركي تحديدا تحدث عن انهيار
1700 مبنى في عشر ولايات تحدث كذلك عن اخر
الاحصائيات
284 قتيلا واصابه
2232 شخصا وزير الداخليه التركي اكد كذلك
ان عمليات الانقاذ مستمر للوصول الى
المحاصرين تحت الانقاض ودعا كذلك مواطني
الى الكف عن استخدام الهواتف المحموله وفي
حصيله اوليه الرسميه حول عدد قتل الزلزال
تركيا اعلن نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد قطاي
ان عدد القتلى في محافظه هاتاي بلغ اربعه
فيما الحصيله حتى الان في محافظه كهرمان
مرعش بلغت 70 قتيلا اما في محافظه اديوان
وصل العدد الى 13 قتيلا وفي ديار بكر 14
قتيلا وكشف نائب الرئيس التركي ان هناك
عشرين قتيلا في محافظه عثمانيه و18 قتيلا
في شنيل اورفا وكان وزير الداخليه التركي
قد اعلن ان الاولويه في الوقت الراهن هي
اخراج المحاصرين تحت المباني المدوره
ونقلهم الى المستشفيات